salut à tous ce nouvel épisode ce soir
un petit peu particulier puisque à la
place du scouting report habituel on a
réuni toute l'équipe et on va débattre
on va revenir sur nos réussites et
surtout sur nos propres erreurs
d'évaluation de la draft 2016 une draft
don bayne simons était sortie faire ce
pic la draft également de timothée
nouveau moka barreau côté français même
si le premier français c'était hier chen
ya blues et les choisis lors de cette
draft 2016 le principe c'est très simple
chacun des membres du podcast est venue
avec sa plus grosse erreur d'évaluation
cette draft là et on va en tirer des
leçons parce que c'est pas simplement
pour s'auto flageller ou s'auto
congratule in on va tirer des leçons et
savoir ce que ça nous apporte dans
l'évaluation des joueurs actuels et
futurs par rapport évidemment à la nba
principalement puisqu'on parle ici de la
draft nba pour ça tout le monde est là
je vais vous citer tous à la file et
vous allez me faire rentrer bonjour
général ni cobain alan manu romain bon
en général
merci c'est l'épisode 6 de la saison 4
d'envergure on est tous ensemble on est
prêt et c'est parti pour un retour brasc
[Musique]
ce
alors drave 2016 pourquoi avant de
donner la parole le premier d'entre vous
braves 2016 parce qu'on attend la fin du
contrat rookie généralement pour juger
évaluer un petit peu de réussite ou non
d'un joueur c'est à dire que l'équipe
qui l'a drafté va l'avoir longtemps de
son contrat rookie est ce qu'elle va le
prolonger à quel prix quelle production
mais ce joueur on peut pas juger au bout
d'un an on ne peut pas encore - jugée au
bout de vingt matches comme certaines
personnes le font actuellement
ça c'est grâce à des lances au salon il
met les doigts dans la prise d'un on va
commencer par ben puisque c'est une
tradition un petit peu ben donne moi ta
plus grosse erreur de la draft 2016 et
ensuite tu nous donnera la leçon qu'il
faut en tirer la drave 2016 c'est grave
parce que j'ai eu beaucoup de réussite
et beaucoup d'erreurs dans le haut du
tableau la plupart des joueurs sont
demeurés un peu sur la trajectoire que
j'avais anticipé de branding m dragan
bender bo diddley story en france mais
en jouant sur lesquels le joueur au
profil sur lesquels je m'étais gorée ces
domaines tasse à boni ce qui est
maintenant un peu le pilier de la tacc
de diane est d'accord avec ça les gars
oui moi sur ce que j'ai vu des médias
mais même si j'en regarde jamais
beaucoup dans la vente à savoir sarah
gonzaga je trouvais que c'était un bon
joueur mais qui était très dans le maule
des vieux qui vaut des jeux pivot
collégiaux il jouait surtout de dos ou
de doro panier il n'était pas
extrêmement longs ils n'étaient pas
extrêmement judicial et je me demandais
comment est-ce qu'on va le faire jouer
en nba je voyais pas exactement je
croyais qu'elle avoir une carrière en
nba mais qui allait avoir
cette carrière en nba ça m'a acheté un
peu sur le cul moi je croyais qu'il
allait être joueur de rotation pendant
quelques années et éventuellement
disparaître parce que je croyais pas que
physiquement ils allaient pouvoir qui
allie allez pouvoir compétitionner avec
les gros pivot de la nbi visiblement je
m'étais trompé la nba a diminué en
format et je pense que d'amateurs
sabonis en tant que pivot est liée à
l'histoire et au plus que le physique
qu'il faut pour compétitionner soir
après soir il nous le démontre je crois
que si je m'abuse il a 21 points 12
rebonds et 6 passes décisives par match
depuis le début de la série all stars en
tout temps exactement ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que lady diana le joue
comme pivot à l'attack et comme ailier
fort en défensive c'est à dire qu'il va
pas garder les plus gros joueurs
défensifs qui va le faire et à l'attaqué
on va le faire jouer près du panier pour
bénéficier de cette à l'an passé
la leçon à d'en bas et que tu m entends
sabonis il a été de racheter puis été
échangé aussi à une équipe qui s'est pas
vraiment posé de questions sur le site
positionnelle je crois que le fait
positionnelle surtout pour des joueurs
de cet âge là je dis s'abonner c'est un
échauffement mais il y avait quoi 20 ans
pour un joueur de cet âge là c'est pas
crucial dans la plupart des cas il ya eu
[Musique]
créatifs autour de lui puis surtout
qu'ils avaient une idée des caisses qui
voulait faire avec lui puis dans
maintenant sabonis c'est absolument
inouïe en tant que pointe center et
points forts wade en juillet un peu à
l'image d'aussi de ce que judy sous un
dôme fait cette année en nba ils sont à
peu de choses près le même joueur
mais ce soir je pense qu'on ne trône on
assure penser magoar que j'ai su
repenser le fit positionnelle avec de
malta sabonis
il était dans plusieurs line up
absolument éclaté avec indian oil avec
oak ici aussi il ya eu droit à beaucoup
de patience et beaucoup d'amour puis
s'est développé en ne jouant que jamais
qui pourrait être justement tu parlais
du manque de mobilité et je pense qu'on
avait tous constaté à l'époque c'était
tous notre crainte
le joueur qui n'est pas vraiment
défendre au périmètre et qui est pas non
plus très verticale pour protéger le
cercle pour pour toi c'est quoi qui
compense aujourd'hui cette ses défauts
qui n'ont pas disparu de montage sabonis
est pas devenu un athlétique du jour au
lendemain c'est quoi qu'ils compensent
ça et qu'on n'a pas et qu'on a du coup
sous-évalué puisque celle qu'on pense je
crois qu'ils aiment balaa parle d'une
bonne compatibilité avec miles kane
je crois que tonneau est capable de
couvrir les plus gros joueurs au
périmètre mais aussi qu'on avait
sous-estimé la force physique de menthe
un symbolisme qui est quand même capable
physiquement le garder plusieurs jours
devant lui et qui est très difficile à a
reculé près du poste bas et c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment un ours sont
violents dans le fond c'est deux choses
qu'on aime vraiment qu'on a vraiment
sous-estimé chez lui il est pas
switchable sur n'importe quelle position
mais il est légèrement à switcher je
pense qu'il peut garder si un fusil sur
la tempe de 3 à 5 en nba donc je dirais
c'est pas un joueur complet mais c'est
un joueur qui dépasse que ce qui apporte
pas facilement compense pour ses lacunes
en termes de mobilité et puis en termes
de verticalité je trouve
messieurs est ce qu'il y en a 1 d'entre
vous qui avait demandé sabonis parmi son
top 8 puisqu'on peut dire aujourd'hui
que c'est un des huit meilleurs joueurs
de ces drafts sans trop se tromper
je l'avais 21e personnellement non pour
moi donc tu l'avais derrière henry l
henson ou pas malheureusement oui
et je l'avais derrière malik beesley
aussi qui tenait absolument
est ce que quelqu'un veut réagir sur le
fait de sous-estimer la force et aussi
la compatibilité même si c'est ça c'est
dur a estimé avant de avant la draft
mais la force d'un joueur je ne sais pas
comment on pourrait l'appliquer à au
draft récente plus récentes de 2020 2021
nico je sais pas si tu as une idée de
joueur fort qui donne des littérateurs
jugnot ouais ouais ouais j'avais la
comparaison pour toi et que réussit pour
l'instant c'est un peu compliqué mais
est il avait pas de coach avant avant le
début de cette année donc du coup on va
on va pouvoir vraiment testé cette année
il fait déjà des performances qui sont
plus intéressantes
après sur sabonis moi à l'époque je
faisais pas de draft comme vous mais le
laisse 'les echos' j'avais est la seule
les sons que j'en ai tiré c'est de pas
donner trop d'importance aux intel parce
que sabonis avait une réputation de deux
bagarreurs de bach quoi c'est le mec qui
a à vilnius cas onas écumé les bars et
ils se prenaient des patates dans la
tronche tous les samedis soirs quoi donc
il ya eu il ya notamment une histoire
dans sa draft où il s'est fait éclater
l'arcade je crois deux semaines avant la
draft
donc ce qui arrive en tournage à 19 ans
oui oui en fait on a le droit d'être con
quand on est jeune et on a le droit
d'évoluer
surtout quand on se retrouve à indiana
c'est plus facile quand on se retrouve à
new york miami et et moi la petite leçon
je retiens ça ça m'a permis impose de
deux d'équilibré statut peut avoir
effectivement des intel un peu un peu
dégueu
du moment que ça dépasse pas une
certaine limite quand c'est à la porte
hingis à la sabonis faut aussi s'adapter
aux coutumes locales alors par coutume
locale illico bien bien entendu dire que
le balte a tendance à tisanes et un
petit peu et être un oiseau de nuit
c'est ça puisque toi tu connais bien tu
as évolué par là bas j'étais plus
j'étais plus au mois gt gt gt gt gt côté
finlandais mais bon c'est les 6 sur le
finlandais est plus calme il picole tout
autant mais il est plus tard
ok alors à qui de par les barreaux
maintien tu as le micro en main le nom
il est posé sur mon bureau le beurre des
huées nain le beurre um1 alors dit moi
vous êtes plutôt quoi plutôt buzz tout
plutôt plutôt que sérieux la suite au
plutôt sérieux un joueur c'est un joueur
dont tu te tapes est un peu surévalué
que tout le monde avait sous-évalué et
peut-être du mal comme ça 3i 36e du coup
36e
36e derrière quelques joueurs cultes
comme rade et zagora tch
tyler ulysse et yodelice ce que vous
avez contre les nains monsieur
absolument rien et beaucoup de pépins
je vous ai choisis quasiment 10 10
places derrière derrière pascal siakam
qui était déjà je trouve une belle
réussite par rapport à son niveau draft
malcom braff donne à l'heure actuelle
sur l'assuré c'est zorro course et 23
points 47% à 3 points et puis ben un
joueur un joueur quand même globalement
le moment puisque plus que plus que
rentable et over à cheever par rapport
aux eaux comment dire aux spots sur les
qualités de racheter bien entendu donc
s'il a clairement un clairement un
rendement de deux stars ou presque sur
le sur le début de saison et par rapport
à par rapport à son spot j'ai pas
penché sur sur ce que donnaient les 37e
choix en général
généralement entre 30 et 40 ont à dire
il ya un ou deux mecs qui finissent
titulaire mais là on est on est au
dessus sur l'évolution sur les contrats
bons sur sa sur sa saison rookie il est
mais il n est je crois un trio qui l'a
dit il a 10 points 10 points 2 rebonds
10 points 3 rebonds par l'omd 4 passes
il sort d'une saison d'une saison senior
à virginia où il est mouillé bon il est
incontournable en acier est là
aujourd'hui
il y là il a évolué statistiquement
d'année en année ils évoluent en termes
de rôles d'année en année il passe un
ordre d'idée de l'importance du joueur
aujourd'hui dans le dans le modèle
économique et de vie passe de huit cent
soixante quinze mille dollars la saison
à un contrat d'un million avec indiana
donc je pense une bien belle réussite de
deux évaluations et de et d'intégration
aéronautique
alors qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que les
équipes nba qu'est ce que nous parce que
même ceux qui l'avaient un peu plus haut
franchement personne n'avait loterie je
pense je l'avais train termine qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce qu'on a ratées
collectivement chez malcolm brockton
est-ce qu'on a sous-estimé l'institution
virginia donne une éthique de travail
c'est sous-estimer aussi le les outils
du joueur qu'est ce qu'elle est ton avis
roman il ya eu fonds il ya peut-être un
petit un petit rat de vagues sur sa
saison sa saison freshman pas ce qui se
dit ici à ce disque à saint-lys casse le
pied il ya red shirt sur l'année
suivante oui où il joue pas en fait
parce qu'il est en rééducation après
après la chirurgie après l'opération
chirurgicale qu'il a eue en en fin de
saison 2012 donc ça peut jouer parce que
ça peut s'appeler c'est un doute
après on y montre malgré tout que il
fait 12 14 et 18 au niveau des points à
3 points il fait 37 34 39 donc ça reste
assez solide mais peut-être qu'il ya un
petit peut-être qu'un petit doute à ce
moment là effectivement sur sur la
capacité du
joueur à passer à passer l'échelle
l'échelon supérieur parce que l'échelle
supérieure sépare français non parce
qu'à l'échelon supérieur donc ça peut ça
peut être un ça peut être un élément de
réponse
made man u est ce que tu as tu as une
idée de vue quelque chose je sais pas si
tu es tu te rappelles de comment tu
l'avait évaluée à l'époque mais malcom
drop donne est ce que qu'est ce qu'on
aurait pu manquer en fait parmi son
skill 7
aujourd'hui c'est un joueur complet
surtout qu'ils jouent à beaucoup avec le
ballon tout et on pouvait douter de
cette utilisation là il faut supérieur à
l'époque
moi c'est pas forcément sur son son jeu
mais plus sur l'encadrement qu'il avait
à dire guignard je pense qu'il faut pas
sous-estimer qu'il était dans un espèce
de cocon est très très très bien coachée
à l'époque c'était l'une des voir la
meilleure équipe du du px avec l'un des
meilleurs coaches et il ça en moi je
trouve qu'il faut pas le sous-estimer je
trouve que c'est ultra important je peux
dire plus ou moins la même chose avec
sabonis oua oua gonzaga c'est pareil il
y avait une vraie famille ça avec marc
you ils sont assez l'équipe des gains en
vrai staff
contrairement à certaines facs qui qui
vise leur leur respect où l'heureux
comment dire ça sur sur le futur des
joueurs suivez mon regard
on voit bien qu'on se transforme on a
mission subversives
c'est sur ces les grosses têtes les
grandes gueules alan qu'est-ce qu'on a
manqué chez michael bolton
sentir je pense moi je n'ai pas
confiance en tirent l'alarmé à la
mécanique était moche je pense quelle
bombe la laisse pas partir et les poires
tirer comme ça autant aussi bien je
crois que c'est l'un des tous meilleurs
shooteurs aux lancers francs
toutes les nuits là elle était en
l'appelant 10% si je me rappelle bien il
prend du sortie dribblant et du poulet
il est capable de bouloc bourdonnement
de même avec sa mécanique un peu bizarre
et et son geste peu académique
il ya des sériés passe parce que ce
n'était pas très beau et moi c'est que
c'est ça qui m'a qui m'a fait pas le le
qui m'a fait le sou sous-évalué le sou
côté je pense
nico tu veux ajouter quelque chose oui
désolé je disais c'est ce que je vous
dis depuis un an donc là je fais un peu
le le mecredi mais je je trouve qu'on
est dans une seconde
en général on donne trop d'importance à
à la mécanique imes sam un light show
temps les mecs quand il arrive à une
vieille il travaille dessus et il arrive
à au final il se met au niveau il y en a
très peu qui qui qui reste avec des tirs
à l'achat de marianne oui mais il ya des
exemples de type qui avait une mécanique
affreuse et des bons pourcentages et qui
du coup ont eu des mauvais pourcentage
en arrivant en nba
oui mais opel je parle de chipoter sur
brock donne
c'était du chipotage certes tu as raison
romain tu avais un buzz aussi on dirait
le mauvais tireur le bon tireur si celui
qui met dans la boîte j'avais je vais un
jeu vers un but un peu ce qu'il en est
en la personne de tonnes mais coeur qui
parle alors attendez je consulte mes
tablait en dise à milwaukee
et où finale aujourd'hui tom baker s'est
péniblement une dizaine de minutes à
trois points de moyenne à clio landes
pour un joueur qui est acté 23 ans 24
cette année je pense qu'on s'approche
quand même doucement mais sûrement du
une sortie de retour d'une sortie de
route voire peut-être de l'europe ou de
quelque chose comme ça parce que il n'a
malheureusement pas malheureusement pas
confirmé ce qu'on pouvait attendre ce
qu'on pouvait espérer pour un joueur
choisit en dise une très bonne summer
league de las vegas en sortie de prep
school 62 matches la première saison
autour de six thèmes de 4 5 points la
deuxième pareil voilà ça ça ça stagne
entre entre 5 et entre 5 et sei six
points vont plus dans des équipes depuis
qu'il est sorti de milwaukee dans les
équipes un petit peu la dérive c'était
des trois maintenant c'est cleveland
s'est pas séparation après là il ya
quelques petites choses qui peuvent
encore le sauver le fait je pense qu'il
ne faut pas du tout passé par là par la
fac
peut-être aussi pas forcément aidé son
développement on peut peut-être encore
lui laisser lier c'est un petit peu de
temps mais ça me paraît malgré tout un
petit peu un petit peu inquiétant pour
lui
ben est ce que tu as tenu sur les
chaussées maker quoi je sais pas si vous
vous rappelez les gars mais les gens
était devenu complètement fou avec tom
et caravanes
je sais pas savez-vous qu'on avait
interviewé un skill coach kabyle qui
avait dit que les webcams de temps mais
que faisait le tour des jeans d'un
billet que tout le monde voulait
travailler avec lui et la plage bla bla
bla et la vérité c'est que tom baker
avait signé avec josh howard comme agent
qui était à l'époque l'agent jason kidd
qui était le coach de 2000 loi qui est
un très bon ami du propriétaire et il a
fait une tournée promotionnelle
de temps de michael subséquentes faut
toujours se méfier quand un joueur monte
dans le ring pour absolument rien parce
que je me rappelle très bien cette année
là lorsqu'on faisait des podcasts etc on
l'avait tous une touche unilatéralement
au deuxième tour ces laiteries vendu son
potentiel était vendu beaucoup beaucoup
plus cher que ce qu'il était prêt à
livrer par josh white et je voudrais je
jouais je vais retrouver d'articles
courts reportages sur twitter il a même
fait venir en avion à orbec pour écrire
un article sur lui pour son potentiel
puis sur l'idée que tout le monde amis
loi qui étend était en amour avec lui
s'il y avait eu une ruée vers lentement
avait complètement perdu nos rapports
portant mais qu' une ruée vers le ton
très écolo oui bah donc automne mais
coeur et qu'il avait du potentiel c'est
surtout qu'il n'a pas progressé
puisqu'il a toujours su potentiel de
mecs plutôt nova il n'y a pas de n'y a
pas d'évolution il est sur des standards
standard qui ne bouge pas en fait alors
c'est bien là un niveau plafond mais à
un niveau plancher je veux dire pardon
mais bon ce qui serait bien si tu es un
petit peu plus après c'est dommage parce
que sont sa participation l'accueil des
équipes d'australie ou aux qualifs aux
qualifs de la coupe du monde en 2019
sont pas une intéressante il y a dix
points 9 rebonds ou 10 points 10 rebonds
quelque chose comme ça il est comme
international dans un pays qui est qui
et qui est très basket en australie ça
reste ça reste une référence au niveau
au niveau international donc ouais c'est
un petit peu un petit peu un petit peu
frustrant est dommage probl s qui
s'était ce tournoi là où s qui s'est
battu avec la bras complet de l'équipe
des philippines ça pourrait les mayas
deux là pourraient être ça pourrait
savourer les grandes philippines
d'andray blatche tu veux dire
absolument les deux organes aldo parkman
les jambes on va rester dans les buzz
puisque je crois que c'est nico qui a
choisi un boss aussi pour son exemple
des erreurs d'évaluation
dragan bender d'ailleurs au nom qui fait
frissonner tout l'arizona
elle est facile celle là quel est le
point commun entre dragan bender avec
christophe poor's hingis chris paul
recevoir groupe chris bosh dikembe
mutombo rasheed wallace et lamar odom la
bagarre dans les bars non non on va déjà
fait à leur nom j'aurais pu rajouter de
janet jackson junior et il est ils ont
été sectionnés en numéro 4 de la draft
voilà oui le qu'il est moins bien
réussit les autres c'est ça ouais un peu
moins bien le fantasme croate et je les
choisis parce que en fait il est les
raisons de son échec elles sont
tellement multiples que c'était super
intéressante se plonger là dedans alors
avec le recul tout le monde aime bien
accuser les scènes c'est à dire oui à
clayessens pour faire une bêtise
pareille et où je me suis replongé dans
dans les morgues drafté dans les
articles tout le monde était chaud sur
lui il était annoncé comme un potentiel
top five
les gens parlent de lui comme quelqu'un
qui avait le potentiel pour devenir une
star à un seven footer qui a été capable
de tirer de dribbles et de faire des
passes donc franchement là dessus on va
on peut dédouaner les suns qui sont tous
tombés amoureux de du joueur et donc
pourquoi ils sont tombés amoureux
alors comme je les dis le fantasme on
est en plein dans le romania avec
nowitzki kaki qui a été championne bien
en 2011 gazole en 2009 et 2010
tipi en 2014 et & poor's hingis a été
drafté l'année d'avant lui aussi en en
quatre et il a fait une année rookie de
exactement c'est un gros facteur
la course in germania en fait je pense
que les suns ont eu peur de passer
encore à côté d'un d'un phénomène et du
coup ils ont ils ont voulu y croire
la seule alors ils ont voulu y croire et
ils ont été bien aidés par la stratégie
de de l'agent de dragan bender qui était
monsieur balducci qui a eu jessica
vicieux et qui était avant de
malheureusement de nos kits et qui était
l'agent denis sève dia et de thé au mali
dont j'ai parlé qu'avec un proche de
balducci qui me disait qu'en gros là
j'en avais pas eu l'impression de
tricher mais qu'il avait eu l'impression
de très bien jouer le jeu pour band
c'est à dire en ciblant 6,7 moment dans
l'année en lui en disant aux joueurs
soient bons à ses 6,7 moment le reste de
l'année
les mecs viendront pas devoir est donc
voilà ils ont amené c'est un peu ils ont
surfé sur robert ghiz clairement ils ont
ils ont caché certains défauts parce que
la principale différence est là où il
n'est pas du tout comparable avec poor's
inglis c'est dans la mentalité d'argane
bender a pas le mental d'un winner il
et il a fait des déclarations un peu
laboris diao quoi moi je préfère faire
des passes que marquez dunk et ce n'est
pas esthétique donc forcément voilà ce
qu'un point en plus un intello un mec
qui avait la tête sur les épaules et il
a eu un peu l'impression d'arriver dans
un monde de bourrin en nba
un monde qui lui convenait pas forcément
qu'on peut en rajouter à ça que le les
suns lepreau le projet de développement
de joueurs c'est pas leur force et qu'
ils n'ont pas tout fait pour pour que
bender puisse atteindre veulent nous il
faut que tout le monde aurait aimé voir
un lit en draft aux martys crise
notamment la même année
parce que si on peut pas les excuser
pour la voir et en quatre
on peut peut-être leur dire que c'était
pas bien de prendre de monter en crise
en 8 parce que ça aussi en lâchant
bogdanovic et compagnie
quand on sait que les implacables
historiographe monop
[Rires]
je suis pas avocat médecin
c'est juste que vraiment j'ai essayé de
lui notre possible n'est ce pas ce qu'on
tape souvent sur le sur l'essonne c'est
là-dessus bon ils n'ont pas tout faux
il ya une partie par contre qu'il aurait
dû c'est sûr et j'oublie ce que je
voulais dire un attendant que tu
retrouves peut-être ben tu me dis allez
dire quelque chose sur ben ouais bah
c'est un autre quand je trouve tout le
monde complètement perdu le nord j'avais
eu l'occasion de regarder des matchs et
ils jouent et greenstein jouer soit 11
minutes par match je crois c'est tir qui
prenait 104 jeunes chaudes c'était pas
gardé c'est pas qu'il n'avait pas le
potentiel c'est que je pense qu'il
voyait beaucoup dans les choses que lui
demander de regarder mon frère c'était
chronique d'un désastre annoncé
j'avais très peur pour le jeune homme
qui tout mais pas en jeu sans confirmer
de plus nico est ce qu'il ya une leçon
vraiment sûr que tu as pu appliquer sur
les évaluations récentes 2020 ou
peut-être 2021 à venir ben la taille la
mobilité les ans le shooting a signé sur
le papier c'est vrai que c'est on signe
tout de suite
mais au final l'importance de de la
qualité du mental de la capacité du
dugas a à se faire mal et est un facteur
prépondérant je pense surtout dans les
dents les profits comme ça alan est ce
que tu avais pender haut comme tout le
monde
est-ce que tu avais déjà un classement
non c'est la première d'europe vous y
fait des côtes case dessus mais c'était
pas mais si je n'en avais pas déneigées
et pas bender haut mais parce que vous
pourrez très honnête aussi je les ai pas
réglé par gad et wii et wii
l'honnêteté no2 s'il a new l'honnêteté
et le mobilier est ce qu'on peut
préciser que ce n'est pas le seul
parce que au final il a beaucoup évolué
en deuxième division il ya très peu de
scouts nba qui sont déplacés sur place
pour le voir jouer en live c'est vrai
est ce que quelqu'un d'autre à une leçon
sur iphone lâchant mais ce qui est à
verser une pause d'un gars qui étaient
disponibles à la draft 2013 et le décès
des deux de prendre une année de plus et
de sortir large 2014 je pense que je
vais le côté freshman c'est peut-être un
peu surévalué
là c'est intéressant comme débat j'ai
pas si nico est d'accord mais je sais
que l'âge c'est un des critères
principaux
oui oui comme et mais la comparaison
avec beijing 10 et ressort sur plein de
sueur plein de domaines et époux ring et
bender était plus prêt prêt plutôt que
par un guide mais pour guy s'il est en
couveuse en espagne ils ont vraiment
pris le temps et avec bender je pense
que tout le monde l'a vu trop tôt trop
beau et finalement la marge de
progression qui est aussi un facteur
important a été a été oubliée dans ce
dans ce cas là parce qu'il n'a pas
évolué sur ces ce qu'ils aient depuis
depuis bas depuis 2016
on retrouve aussi l'importance de la
force comme on disait tout à l'heure un
petit peu le bender il n'a jamais mais
c'est important donc oui joueurs forts
qui se font par h et les ballons pas
dans les stades qui sont pas arrachés
les ballons qui explose au contact c'est
pas forcément évident
manu c'est à toi qui es qui est ton
joueur et quelle est ta leçon
bonjour c'est d'y aller nous sommes donc
aujourd'hui aux celtics donc à la fac ce
temps joueurs qui étaient à ces bandes 6
kills et membres des groupes omar
mais qui avait eu un gros gros manque de
shoot
c'était son ca plus sa plus grosse
faiblesse au soir de la draft et qui du
coup il avait un peu de mal a ajouté que
ce soit à mi distance soit 3 points
notamment assortie dribbles etc et en
arriver à boston et qui par endroits hu
à un joueur qui s'est métamorphosé et le
mal sont en fait avec lui ses plus hauts
niveaux un peu le mental mais surtout
sur la connaissance de soi même sur les
je me rappelle de désign fairview kraft
qui faisait avec les médias il racontait
souvent que beaucoup il ya une phrase
qui m'est restée en tête depuis il avait
dit beaucoup se prennent pour kobe
outils match mais personne ne travaille
comme me le font et du coup il a il a
toujours dit toujours dit que son shoot
c'était vraiment la plus grosse chose at
il devait travailler et il prenait
exemple sur justement sur ces joueurs
sur ce le travail la work éthique était
ultra important et du coup il a montré
aussi tombé dans le ventre dans la bonne
situation je pense où il a au fil des
années il a évolué un assez formidable
ans hurle le shoot de travaux à trois
points où il est passé de 34% à sa
saison rookie à jeu petit plus prendre
la saison dernière où il termina 38%
avec d'une progression 6 sur la la prise
de shoot où il prenait d'entre eux
empêchent un et deux choses 1 3 point
sur sa saison rookie et l'année dernière
j'étais quasiment à 6 par match
donc c'est assez énorme et au final bah
c'est pas forcément un humble
enfin c'est pas une erreur de jugement
que j'avais sur sur lui c'est vraiment
le fait où il m'a impressionné c'est
qu'il a réussi à progresser mais
vraiment d'année en année et on le on
l'a vu sur le terrain
effroi que nous connaître moi je pensais
je pensais qu'ils allaient réussir
n'importe où mais je pensais pas qu'ils
allaient réussir aussi vite et c'est
vraiment moi ce que je retiendrai là
dessus c'est vraiment ça cette
intelligence
générale qu'il a eu sur lui de savoir si
tu lui manquait pour réussir en fait
c'est intéressant parce que l'on parlait
tout à l'heure de nico parlait dans
bender un peu intellectuel et c'est john
brown était vu comme ça aussi à sa
sortie de la fac déjà aujourd'hui sert
des joueurs les plus engagés plus
d'opinions de la nba mais enfin qui
montrent le plus ses opinions et qui
s'exprime là dessus qui consciente du
rôle social qu'il a joués etc
mais john grant c'était quelqu'un qui
était vu un peu comme l'intellectuel qui
sait pas si faisait déjà de la philo
mais voilà il faut aux échecs n'ai pas
d'argent ce pardon à d'argent c'est pas
d'argent c'est vrai et ça c'est quelque
chose dont il sortait un peu du lot là
dessus mais du coup il avait pas cet
aspect un peu soft si on peut dire de
dragan bender coualy il savait où il
voulait aller il savait ce qu'il fallait
faire pour y aller
romain comment on peut évaluer le mental
d'un joueur on avait eu un podcast là
dessus sur les stades psychologique mais
comment toi tu tu ressens le ces
évaluations là en fait qu'ils sont on
s'en rend compte tout au long de la lys
et on le savait déjà et on le répète
souvent prépondérante
et c'est sans doute le critère numéro 1
d'évaluation
je suis pas forcément experts en la
matière moi j'ai tendance à dire que on
arrive aujourd'hui sur d'aller sur des
sur deux niveaux de connaissance dans
tout ce qui gravite autour du sport avec
des vrais expertise donc je vais donner
un avis mais qui sera partiel est
certainement pas totalement juste au
regard de ce que pourrait donner un
après par un préparateur mental ou
quelqu'un spécialisés de l'enviable et
d'idées on voulait d'avoir appelé cibc
je te demande c'est parce que toi tu les
fréquentes professionnellement aussi ses
moments moi je dirais que les critères
sur lesquels je m'arrête sont très
souvent liée à du adua du verbe à la du
non verbal
parce que je suis il faut toujours faire
la distinction entre les discours
d'intention parfois très dire très
formaté et très programmée des gens qui
qui veulent tout donner pour le maillot
ceci cela pour moi très souvent cdc des
conneries parce que quand on grade il
faut ce qu'il faut c'est gratter voir ce
qu'il ya derrière
donc il ya vraiment ses dents dans dans
la rhétorique dans la façon de
s'exprimer des gens dans le façon dont
les gens vont être capables de de
formuler leurs projets je dirais que
quand j'ai changé avec des joueurs ou
des joueuses c'est plus c'est plus ça
qui m'intéressait c'est la voir ce qui
est un petit peu derrière ce cette
espèce du trio de discours de façade
j'ai souvent eu mois la discussion avec
les clés qui jeunes jouaient ce que j'ai
pu en équipe de france
moi chaque fois qu'une me dis pas je
vais tout donner pour le maillot où il
met quoi se dire quoi ce qu'est ce que
tu vas faire concrètement qu'est ce que
tu veux apporter concrètement c'est
vraiment être capable d'aller chercher
ça après après il façon encore plus
simple d'évaluer les gens c'est de voir
comment il se comporte sur le terrain
c'est à dire il faut faire la faute
toujours faire la différence entre sur
des choses toutes simples par exemple
une valeur on va dire de tel ou tel
joueur qu'il est qu'il est arrogant
qu'il est hautain il faut toujours faire
la différence entre ça et la
détermination parfois se comprend pour
de lego c'est simplement un très haut
niveau de détermination
c'est un exemple parmi tant d'autres les
réactions vous avez des joueurs desquels
on va dire il est pas capable de
s'excuser il parle peu non c'est qu'il
ya des gens dont le moteur et dont on ne
les aspects motivationnelle sont pas
sont pas conduire liée à une capacité à
s'exprimer et à s'exprimer ça à
verbaliser les choses verbalement ou à
montrer des émotions quelqu'un quelqu'un
comme kawaii lenard en fonction du du le
du contexte dans lequel on évalue on
peut très bien voir des gens on va dire
entre guillemets non avertis ou mon
expert qui vont se poser l'action suis
dit ah le mec ne montre rien pourquoi
qu'est ce que ça cache et on peut
prendre sa part du manque de confiance
sur leurs hôtes pour la timidité ou pour
une armée de deux critères de
comportement différent donc c'est
toujours très c'est toujours très très
complexe en fait de pouvoir évaluer ces
choses là mais ce qu'ils ne travaillent
jamais les situations de difficultés sur
le terrain c'est à dire que le
leadership c'est pas forcément être
vocal barrier compagnie le leadership
c'est aussi parfois
ben ce que ce que ce que disent souvent
les scouts où les où les coaches
hennetier célibat examen porte salers et
c'est l'attitude qui va qui va aussi
montrer leadership donc il ya pris ya
toute une gamme je dirais un spectre de
d'éléments à soi prendre en compte soit
regardé je pense que en fonction de sa
sensibilité perso c'est aussi quelque
chose qu'il vous faut pas l'oublier
je ne regarderai jamais un joueur de la
façon tu le feras puisque de toute façon
intrinsèquement nos sensibilités de nos
personnalités font qu'on regarde on ne
regardera pas la même chose et on ne
sera pas sensiblement chose en termes de
réaction
en résumé je dirais que c'est pas
répondre à la question en fait si à part
quelques je pense me présenter aux
législatives bientôt ce que je travaille
sur lesquels s'est concentré sur les
dents je vais trouver une
circonscription au lit ce que je
travaille sur l'éloquence si je suis le
jeu voilà non mais je blague à part
c'est c'est quelque chose de très
complet et j'aime beaucoup échangé sur
le sujet avec avec mes collègues et
également avec des gens dont c'est le
métier
j'ai hâte d'avoir la réaction de par
exemple de guillaume vizada qui le coach
de 10,6 clairement qu'ils nous écoutent
très régulièrement et puis qu'on
essaiera de faire venir depuis le temps
qu'on le salue la réaction de dywidag
par rapport à ça parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui a une sensibilité de ce
côté là sur l'évaluation des gens si
l'album de redonner la parole manu nico
pour tout ce qui est mental aussi une
semble avoir je peux je peux renvoyer
vers une vidéo tu parles de ton métier
d'évaluateurs pour le mental il ya aussi
simplement regarder comment la personne
se comporte dans les moments importants
c'est juste que j'aime c'est juste que
je viens de dire ben oui mais c'était
pour aller là dessus oui mais toi tu as
parlé du match en général etc
l'idpe eyes by example mais là je te
parle des merveilles sur et en dehors du
terrain wesley des cinq dernières
minutes d'un match serré par exemple les
jeunes joueurs ont aussi le droit
d'évoluer sur ce plan là il y en a il ya
de plus en plus de joueurs qui prennent
des coach mental je pense que là dessus
romain sera d'accord avec moi la
meilleure place possible quand on va
voir des jeunes c'est derrière le banc
par vous voir même on veut à filer un
petit peu derrière la table de marque du
côté du bon visiteurs surtout à cholet
s'abstraire une petite private joke pour
les noms de soirée mémorable avec
charlie tôt qu'on a passée à cholet
charlie tôt la mascotte de cholet basket
bien sûr qu'on salue au passage à
saguenay et donc oui le la manière toile
le tournoi aéraulique junior à partir du
moment où un gros prospects sors tu vois
la tête de tous les scouts tout le monde
me regarde on regarde plus le terrain on
regarde comment il va s qui va taper
dans la main de son coach et ce qui va
discuter est ce qu'il va faire la gueule
c'est pas tout mais c'est des choses qui
nous en disent long et surtout dans les
moments chauds
parce que dans les moments chauds il ya
plus de ont fait pas semblant on est
soi-même et après ça veut pas dire que
les mauvaises choses on note moi j'ai
l'habitude de dire on a toujours besoin
d'au moins un connard par équipes donc
du coup si un mec on il a été identifié
comme ça on sait que c'est on va le dire
là on va travailler sur cooper catherine
rocco père catching humainement huawei
ccc zéro sur vingt est grave 2021 oui ce
qui suit fait c'est pas pour ça qu'il
sera pas drafté il faut pour les gens
d'origine croate qui nous écoutent nous
pouvons nous de vous donner l'adresse de
nico sans aucun problème vous réglez vos
comptes
oui ça va être complice a va être
quelque chose à prendre en compte dans
l'évaluation mais pas trop c'est il ya
différents profils dans une équipe c'est
actuelle est dir est exactement c'est à
prendre en compte et est pour moi le
soir de la draft
bon après je suis très porté là dessus
mais il ya le le fit sportif mais aussi
le film psychologique
si vous avez avec dennis rodman et
rasheed wallace et ben vous drafté par
cooper cacher mais par contre une équipe
un peu soft cas besoin d'un mec qui va
mettre des tartes dans la tête de deux
de ses coéquipiers ben il faut le
prendre absolument ça c'est quelque
chose extrêmement intéressant et assez
difficiles à identifier puisque les
joueurs bougent beaucoup en plus que
donc assez compliqué à identifier la
construction d'équipements nu
john browne qu'on n'imaginait pas
réussir aussi bien aussi vite tu disais
est ce que tu t'es servi de cet exemple
là pour modifier des évaluations plus
tard est ce que tu as des exemples de la
draft plus récentes
j'ai déjà un exemple sur la draft qui va
arriver c'est scotty lewis de flo rida
qui est un peu le même prototype de
joueurs c'est un joueur très intelligent
aussi genre par exemple pendant les
différentes s'émeut tout problème racial
qui s'est passé aux états unis pendant
la crise a dit l'intersaison il a
beaucoup participé à des manifestations
il a beaucoup participé à cette prise de
parole mais c'est quelque chose qui me
dit qu'il est intelligent et qui connaît
un peu s'y glisser le fait qu'il a
décidé de revenir en floride il a décidé
de refaire une deuxième saison et on
voit qu'il est comme mieux utilisé par
son coach et il est moins floue lui même
sur le terrain on voit qu'il a changé
qu'il a compris des plus de choses
intéressantes scotty lewis donc qu'on
est un joueur ultra athlétique comme
l'étaient déjà les bras un peu plus
petit et donc on va être amené à parler
dans les évaluations pour la draft et
2021 et c'est intéressant de donner ce
nom maintenant puisque c'est vrai
qu'avant sa saison freshman ils étaient
prêtes dans le top 20 de tout le monde
et puis la bce puisqu'il a fait une sale
saison
manu est ce que tu avais d'autres
d'autres le sont avec d'autres joueurs
ou est-ce que ça allait juste rajouter
un truc par appareil ce qui a été dit
avancer sur le le comment dire ça
le ressenti visuel nico disait j'aime
bien regarder ce qui se passe sur le
banc moi je suis exactement pareil mais
j'aime bien aussi de regarder ce qui se
passe avant la rencontre et c'est
l'échauffement où on peut déjà
l'attitude du joueur s'il est un peu je
m'en foutiste ou s'il est déjà focus sur
le sur le truc et ça c'est quelque chose
que j'aime bien regarder c'est ce que
fait un peu sur ces très vieux nico s'en
rappellera peut-être on s'était croisé
pas première fois
c'était un final fort 2000 le 16 10 16
juin à 18 heures où il y avait qu il y
analyse
ouais ça ça et le et je me rappelle
c'est kevin qui m'avait dit regarde un
peu qu'ils canalisent à l'échauffement
tu vas voir il ya des trucs qui vont pas
effectivement on voi le mec qui recte
qu'on avait strictement mais rien à
[ __ ] où il faisait des exercices par
exemple des montées de genoux toi oui
voilà il faisait rien ils trottinaient
en fait et ça c'était pour moi c'est
très important parce que tu cites est
pas faux cul sur tes le début même si
c'est qu'un échauffement
il mouille c'est quelque chose qui avait
dit aussi aux romains dans les années
précédentes c'est tu sais jamais qui
regarde tu sais jamais qui a dans la
salle et du coup si déjà t'es pas
concentrés dès le début avant
qu'eux-mêmes match commence franchement
pour moi c'est ça c'est pas rédhibitoire
mais presque
t'es pas professionnel quoi bon à
l'occurrence killian s est bien sorti
jusqu'ici même si malheureusement il
s'est blessé récemment c'est nier pour
elle parce que moi là je lui ai bien sûr
alan c'est à vous à moi alors qui est
pourquoi et quel vaisseau moi c'est
jamal murray et c'était et c'est avoir
raison mais pour les mauvaises raisons
et je pense que c'est un truc tu as
parlé ne pas juger après 20 matchs tout
à l'heure les rookies et je veux pas
sortir tout de suite mon ak 47 un mail
et des gentils âgées raison sur intel
rookie en fait des fois c'est pas
vraiment pour les bonnes raisons
oui ils ont raison mais c'est c'est
parce qu'ils avaient vu tout ce qu'ils
pensent avoir vu qui fait que ça marche
et pour moi malgré ces c'est le bon
exemple et c'est surtout une leçon sur
elle et one donne qui vont dans les gros
programme est qu en tant qu en fait ça
les genres comme diamal murray la grosse
saison à cannes tu dis grosse saison au
shoot
moi j'étais à végéter très haut sur lui
parce que j'adorais sentir et je pensais
pas qu'il allait devenir se bat ce qu'on
sait de manière de jeu en fait très fort
sur pick'n roll parce qu'en fait on
n'avait pas vu faire ça à kindu qui
cherchait
j'ai recherché dans les stades 4 89% des
tirs à trois points est une passe qui
prenait 11 % disent était en sortie de
comme tout le monde à abu jamal murray
dans la bulle et les moins bien il prend
beaucoup de séances hors titre et
beaucoup de pick and roll sendai on
n'avait pas pu voir en fait à kenji
quitte donc dire que on était très haut
sur murray et qu'on pensait qu'il allait
être sumner dominante c'est pas possible
en fait parce qu'on n'avait pas vu pour
ça que ça m'amène à dire que pour les
gros freshman one donne et mes deux
exemples c'est murray tatum
il faut les regarder dans d'autres
contextes très jeune et il faut pas
tirer 80-90 prendre son évaluation d'un
joueur sur sa seule saison initiez vous
regardez aussi du fiba et même du lycée
autres si on peut parce que ils n'ont
pas les mêmes rôles dans chacune de ces
situations de ces contextes et on voit
des gens on voit des types de joueurs
différents qui réagissent à des types de
collective des types de construction d'
équipes différentes et ça permet une
évaluation plus globale à dire que oui
si on pouvait adoré diamal murray ou
jason tato mais en fait s'ils sont si
forts que ça c'est pas avec ce qu'ils
avaient montré en initier ce qu'ils
avaient montré dans d'autres types de
deux contextes donc voilà c'est sur ça
que j'ai raté que je travaille depuis
alan est ce que tu es à retranscrire ça
sur des évaluations récentes bajur oui
s'ils essayent de les gérer de le faire
j'essaie de le faire notamment avec ba
un joueur qui va pas capables ou encore
ses challengers il y avait un article
qui va sortir prochainement que j'ai que
j'ai eus que je viens de finir revenons
en au registre du ring ring
ou en fait j'ai essayé je pense que si
ça se passe mal angeliki tous qui s'il a
des mauvais passage angélique beaucoup
de gens vont juger le joueur sur son
passage
son passage angélique pour tout temps je
pense qu'on peut tirer autant de choses
sur lui à son âge bas de toutes ces
compétitions fiba qui l'a fait on a fait
3 et de son sens comment ça s'appelle
sont ces sauces et match de lycée et un
autre genre c'est pitié washington bill
clinton qui avait accueilli durant sa
première année un rôle pas exceptionnel
mais dans sa deuxième année il a eu le
même rôle qu'il avait eu avec team usa
dans une des équipes
ce rôle de potentiellement stretch rise
playmaker au poste 4 5
donc c'est le voir dans différents
contextes sama savary permis le plus
glamour je pense bill clinton absolument
on l'a d'or budget qui s'éclate avec la
mélo ball en ce moment du côté de
charlotte qui comme djamel murray dont
tu as parlé
ce qui m'interpelle un peu belge de
faire réagir là-dessus c'est le fait que
jamal murray n'était n'est pas vraiment
un bonheur à kentucky il l'est devenu
est-ce qu on surévalue la création des
joueurs c'est à dire moi j'ai beaucoup
d'exemples à chaque fois deux joueurs
qui au début on se dit quand on les
évalue un ancien on dit oui mais il faut
pas de passe etc
mais par contre il provoque beaucoup de
fautes ils vont au cercle est-ce que
c'est pas un truc qui s'apprend beaucoup
plus facilement que le reste je vais
dire des banalités mais tu te faire la
différence en un contre un par exemple
ben oui et non je crois que c'est tout
dépendant du contexte un joueur pourra
créer énormément pour lui même ou pour
les autres
jamal marie et turner mais on parle
d'une équipe ici qui se fient à nicole
richie pour organiser son programme
sonate acquis c'est nicolas you catch
qui quel ballon d'habitude donc german
maurice pour lui demande beaucoup c'est
faire des points s'est fadé point de
créer de l'attak parce qu'on parle d'une
équipe qui offensivement et pas de
doigté de
plusieurs personnes qui peuvent face à
de manière massive mais un peu peut-être
un peu peut-être si vous êtes si un
joueur arrive dans une équipe où ce qui
a absolument aucune création à ce qu'il
ya où est ce que personne n'est capable
de créer pour ces teams est là il va y
avoir un problème si ce joueur est pas
capable de faire ça mais je pense qu'on
surestime peut-être un peu parce que
dans plusieurs équipes il ya plusieurs
options puis la position de meneur et là
une déposition l'été avec le plus de
profondeur à une bille et donc peut-être
un peu oui très bien ce que vous avez
d'autres leçons à tirer de cette draft
2016 les uns les autres on voyage on
rejoue sans oublier que je croyais que
on voit si t'es dès les mois benvenuti
benben t-il
oui absolument quel qui prenait 35 sous
les parents soient pas glace aujourd'hui
au bout d'un pardon alan contre 9 passé
par charles laurence cossé par chance
une bonne et on se rappelle ben disait
de sa summer league dead mais prenait 50
tirs par match avec boston je crois
c'était magnifique robe nude unicopa de
tas d'autres leçons à tirer de cette
draft 2007
alors un petit juste souvent le souvent
les gens pensent que les scouts n'ont
pas droit de se tromper
il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de scouts
qui est qui qui a bon 100 % des cas les
mecs qui ont fait écrit les rapports sur
stephen curry oui ils ont honte c'est
sûr mais mais en même temps personne n'a
de boule de cristal
donc du coup se trompe et je trouve que
c'est la meilleure chose qui peut
arriver un jeune scout quand il comprend
pourquoi il s'est trompé et pouvoir
mettre en perspective ces erreurs c'est
top moi j'adorais qu'on fasse ça sur
toutes les conneries que j'ai fait un
jeu jose
j'en ai fait beaucoup parce que je
trouve que ça permet d'être un meilleur
scouts après un principe aux offices du
jour je vous souhaite une bonne fin
comme média comme m'a dit comme a dit
l'assistant gel d'une franchise que je
connais plutôt bien scouter sur l'allier
dénoncé pour ce très bon ça j'adore
eh bien nous n'avons pas rayer de nom ce
soir mais nous avons appris ensemble de
nos erreurs et c'est ça le plus
important
c'est pourtant ce qu'on soit quand même
la bienveillance est très importante
chez envergure merci beaucoup monsieur
pour cet épisode riche et on pourra
ressortir
merci à tous les 5,6 g + 5 pour et puis
on vous retrouve très bientôt un article
à lire
adidas next generation de valence le
bilan avec les forces les joueurs qui
ont surpris les joueurs qui ont confirmé
les joueurs qui ont un peu déçu
et puis article à venir celui de la lan
/ / john green le phénomène de geely qui
est attendu dans le top 5 de la draft
est ce qu'il le vaut vraiment ça sera
sur notre site envergure pensée ou comme
tous nos podcasts et pour nous écouter
c'est soit sur le site soit sur votre
blog votre plateforme d'écouté vous vous
abonnez vous n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner et vous mettez des étoiles si
vous aimez bien voilà gros bisous tout
le monde
à bientôt ciao
[Musique]